[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires avec l'ensemble
des télévisions en régional et local de
france
nous allons examiner évidemment les
conséquences de cette crise du bournat
virus les questions sanitaires
économiques sur l'ensemble du territoire
une convention d'ailleurs ce journal
tout de suite par le déplacement du
président de la république cette semaine
en bretagne
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la république se rend à saint pol de
léon dans le nord finistère
il y est venu pour rendre hommage à ce
qu'il a appelé la deuxième ligne c'est à
dire l'ensemble du monde agricole qui
nourrit le pays pendant le confinement
vous voyez ici
des images tournées par nos confrères
est partenaire du quotidien le
télégramme
direction la savoie maintenant la crise
sanitaire a littéralement transformé les
hôpitaux ces dernières semaines sur
place
c'est notamment le cas à chambéry au 15
avril 64 personnes atteintes du
quotidien étaient hospitalisés et au
plus fort de la crise le 31 mars 92
personnes y étaient encore hospitalisés
les patients pris en charge dans des
circuits de a à z
alors comment ça marche la tension dix
minutes elle sur le système hospitalier
en savoie nous faisons le point avec ce
reportage de fanette du buisson pour nos
confrères de 8 mont blanc parfois le 15
souvent les urgences pour les plus
atteints ou des transferts d'autres
établissements plusieurs porte d'entrée
pour une même pathologie
le coc vide 19 à l'intérieur de
l'hôpital depuis plusieurs semaines deux
circuits cohabitent les coïts plus et
l'écho vide - le circuit covit plus
effet deux portes de barrières de
masques et de blues ils sont encore une
soixantaine de cas avérés à être
hospitalisées dans les différents
services de chambéry ici la vague semble
s'éloigner on sent que la pression et
par train de diminuer fortement
pour l'ad moins en moins d'entrées en a
plus en plus de patients qui sont donc
vides qui rendent pour d'autres médicaux
respiratoire mais qui sont pas atteints
par le vide des les patients peuvent ils
sont en train de diminuer
à peu près une dizaine actuellement
aujourd'hui les entrées sont plus rares
que les sorties - d'essoufflement plus
de fièvre des constantes satisfaisante
vincenzo s'apprête à retrouver ses
proches et sa vallée mourier neige après
un passage à l'hôpital de
saint-jean-de-maurienne et en
pneumologie h en mairie
sa sortie est prévue dans l'après-midi
mais
au niveau du personnel ils sont très
très très sympa que nous il n'y a pas
beaucoup de différence à un premier jour
et aujourd'hui vous sentez pas en forme
non pas tout à fait non sans voix en
léger mieux oui mais ça fait quand même
entre saint jean de maurienne au 13e
jour du repos donc beaucoup pour
vincenzo et des masques les patients de
retour à domicile doivent emporter
pendant les sept jours qui suivent leur
sortie 75 % des hospitalisés rentrer
chez eux après leur passage à l'hôpital
mais pour les plus fragiles une étape
supplémentaire est parfois nécessaire
depuis mardi 8 lits dédiés ont été
ouverts en soins de suite et de
réadaptation qui peut bien sûr y avoir
des séquelles spécifique au corona virus
notamment sur le plan respiratoire
les gens peuvent rester essoufflé au
décours de réflexion est plus à côté de
ça pour les personnes âgées il ya des
complications entre guillemets
classiques qui peuvent survenir après
coronavirus comme après n'importe quel
autre événement médical depuis le début
de la crise 130 patients que vite plus
de l'hôpital de chambéry ont pu rentrer
chez eux
une fin de parcours positive qui soulage
malades familles et soignants
parlons à présent de nos aînés vous le
savez le gouvernement a autorisé la
reprise des visites dans les ehpad un
peu partout en france
un soulagement pour les résidents privé
durant de longues semaines de lien
direct avec leur famille et leurs
proches une reprise toutefois géométrie
variable établissement par établissement
où la sécurité sanitaire est bien sûr la
priorité exemple de retrouvailles
chargées d'émotion dans deux ehpad à
rambervilliers et thaon les vosges avec
les équipes de nos confrères devient
vosges regarder cela faisait un mois et
demi que ses résidents de l'ehpad de
rambervillers n'avait pas pu voir leurs
proches en vrai la tente était
évidemment très forte des personnes
âgées comme des membres de leur famille
[Musique]
témoin des mois c'est le pain gain vous
savez la solitude quand ça commence
après
c'est pas comment ça peut se terminer un
dell annonce dimanche par le premier
ministre de la réouverture possible des
ehpad aux visiteurs les standards des
établissements ont été très sollicités
mais concrètement au regard des mesures
sanitaires à mettre en place il leur
faut parfois du temps pour s'organiser
celui de rambervillers compte 102
résidents seulement quatre d'entre eux
ont été contaminés par le kobe de 19 mai
le virus n'a fait aucune victime
ici la direction a proposé des visites
dès ce mardi en extérieur uniquement et
il était temps l'impact psychologique du
confinement était de plus en plus
ressentie y en a qui baissent les bras
parce qu ils voient pas leurs proches
mais bon on essaye de les remonter comme
on peut vous avez un masque aussi s'il
ya la boîte qui est sur la table
une situation vécue de façon similaire
dans cette haute et pas de celui des
cuves hier à cap avenir vosges cette
structure privée a rouvert ses portes
aux visiteurs ce mercredi les rencontres
se font au travers d'une plaque de
plexiglas à tour de rôle
je suis heureux de l'avoir vu et en même
temps je peux pas vous cacher qu'on ait
quand même un pincement au coeur d'être
derrière la vitre de pas pouvoir la
toucher
ici les 62 résidents étaient confinés
depuis le 9 mars soit quelques jours
avant la date officielle du début du
confinement
le personnel avait pressenti la crise
aucune victime directe du coc vide 19
n'est pour l'heure à déplorer
reste que ces six semaines ont été
difficiles à vivre pour tout le monde
afin que tu sais pas c'est pas agréable
que tu n'es que je vous dise
moi je fais pas de l'histoire l'a tué
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça pour eux
qui ont l'habitude d'être tous ensemble
toute la journée ils ont vraiment cette
sensation malgré tout
que c'est eux qui sont isolés quoi ils
font face à la crise et vous pouvez
toujours compter sur eux
les médecins répondent présents en fait
période de pandémie on peut continuer à
se faire soigner pour une suspicion de
coronavirus mais aussi pour d'autres
mots c'est d'ailleurs une inquiétude
pour le gouvernement puisque vous seriez
de plus en plus nombreux à ne plus vous
rendre chez votre praticien pour vous
faire soigner vos médecins ont pourtant
adopté leur pratique face au risque de
propagation du virus
comme le montre ce reportage de nos
confrères de canal 32 à
saint-julien-les-villas dans l'aube
regarder cela fait 35 ans que le docteur
peau de lips qui exercent dans son
cabinet sans c1 depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant il a dû adapter sa
pratique à la pandémie de covin 19
hargeisa médecins généralistes s'adonne
que on ne sait pas toujours si les gens
sont donc atteints ou par on ressort
beaucoup d'anxiété dans la population
donc on a dû adapter nos conditions
d'exercice cette pandémie
auparavant j'avais beaucoup de
consultations sans rendez vous donc non
programmés on est à passer toutes les
consultations en consultation avec
rendez-vous qu'on a retirés de
nombreuses chaises de la salle
d'attentes pour n'avoir plus que deux
entre chaque patient en fait un média un
peu approfondis ont déjà fait que le
bureau des chaises les poignées de porte
le divan d'examen dans un second temps
ce médecin généraliste a saisi les
opportunités numériques autorisé durant
la période de crise sanitaire
en effet les modalités de
téléconsultation ont été assouplies par
un décret publié le 10 mars dernier
j'ai téléchargé donc un petit logiciel
pour faire des téléconsultations et
après les gens qui étaient suspectes de
la maladie on les prenait donc en
téléconsultation c'est surtout de voir
s'ils sont dans une période où c'est
grave ou pas grave s'il faut les envoyer
à l'hôpital
est-ce que vous avez beaucoup de ciels
vous avez est-ce que vous avez des gênes
respiratoires est ce que vous avez des
douleurs thoraciques quelques votre
fréquence respiratoire à augmenter la
fréquence cardiaque légalement est-ce
que vous avez des troubles de l'odorat
des troubles ou donc tout le temps ça
permet de pouvoir juger à peu près de la
gravité des choses
selon ce médecin le nombre de
consultations a été divisé par deux
voire trois depuis le début du
confinement
mais les patients malades peuvent et
doivent continuer à être suivi
évidemment la situation que nous vivons
tous peut s'avérer stressante et
déprimante pour certains c'est pourquoi
un habitant de moselle propose des
séances d'accompagnement mental ça se
passe depuis chez lui à annie der wiel y
est près de sarrebourg ils souhaitent
venir en aide aux personnes en
difficulté regardez ce reportage de
florian tôt nizzo devient mirabel sur
place depuis sa chambre
easy simba enregistre ses vidéos et
continue de prodiguer ses conseils
ce jeune homme de 29 ans s'est lancé au
mois de janvier dernier en tant que
préparateur physique et mentale en plus
d'une activité de coach sportif
en plus d'une licence staps ici ça
passait une formation en ligne proposé
par raphaël au mât pour lancer son
entreprise confinement oblige
fini les rencontres en face à face tout
se fait par visioconférence et pour isis
la méthode de travail reste la même
super merci au caire en sorte que la
personne en face tout - il à se
connaître elle même aussi en fonction de
ce qu'il va me dire je vais lui poser
plusieurs questions et ont donné il ya
je suis si bien un blocage
on va parler reparler ça je vais lui
poser des questions
et parce que moi je fonctionne
énormément par questionnement je donne
pas la réponse tout de suite beaucoup de
questions qui va amener la personne tout
doucement à s'orienter vers une autre
perception de ce qu'elle est je vais
donner ensuite quelques astuces
quelqu'un commet des robes qu'elle coûte
solutions les solutions en question des
exercices ludiques à réaliser à la
maison
au fil de la journée je vais donner un
entraînement offrir de relaxation ou je
lui dis ah bah tu vas faire ça
tant de fois dans la journée où je lui
ai donné le dire voilà tu va accrocher
des des choses dans la maison et à
chaque fois que tu vas tomber sur ces
petits mots là tu vas faire quelque
chose
une séance de coaching mental dure entre
45 minutes et une heure en cette période
de confinement faire appel à un
accompagnateur mental n'est pas de trop
surtout pour les sportifs et les
acharnés de travail pour qui cette
situation peut s'avérer particulièrement
stressante voire même déprimante sont
une activité qu'ils ont fait ils font
ils ont rien commence à venir
le jeune entrepreneur mosellan coûte une
dizaine de clients et quelques nouvelles
demandes depuis le début du confinement
et comme il n'en a jamais assez
isis passe régulièrement d'autres
formations il prépare actuellement un
diplôme universitaire en optimisation de
la performance au creps de nancy dans
quelques jours et bien se fera le 1er
mai fête du travail et jours de forte
mobilisation syndicale
cette année les manifestations sont
interdites mais vous allez le voir dans
ce reportage de nos confrères de tl7 à
saint-etienne tous ne baisse pas les
bras et certains redoublent
d'ingéniosité pour garder à l'esprit
cette fête du 1er mai regardé pour la
première fois dans la loire il n'y aura
pas la traditionnelle manifestation du
1er mai mais pour la journée des
travailleurs
syndicats veulent quand même se faire
entendre malgré le confinement
plusieurs militants ont d'ailleurs déjà
ap la cgt pour savoir ce qui était
organisé le 1er mai alors les principaux
syndicats du département se sont réunis
lundi après-midi en visioconférence pour
réfléchir à de nouvelles formes de
mobilisation et une idée est sorti du
lot l'idée donc serait de devoir
solliciter les médias pour voir si on
pouvait trouver sur un credo commun qui
pourrait être dans le créneau de l'heure
de la manifestation
la possibilité d'organiser un débat
tarvisio
évidemment les autres fois on a des
reportages sur les manifs avec des
interviews des choses comme ça on les
vire l'os et c'est sur ce créneau de
tendre manif d'essayer de faire
différemment et de donner quand même la
parole aux travailleurs et de manière à
ce qu'ils nous fassent part 2e et aussi
comment comment ils voient le jour
d'après une chose est sûre la cgt
n'appellera personnes à descendre dans
la rue le 1er mai impossible en effet de
respecter la distance d'un mètre entre
chaque manifestant l'année dernière il y
avait eu 3000 personnes à saint-etienne
la situation est inédite depuis la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale les
ligériens n'ont jamais manqué le rendez
vous de la fête du travail
toujours à propos du 1er mai un brin de
muguet est une tradition très partagée
dans notre pays vous le savez cette
année la vente sauvette sera totalement
interdite sur le territoire national une
information du site actus.fr le ministre
de l'agriculture qui annonce dans cet
article de nos confrères que les 14000
fleuriste de france resteront fermés en
ce jour symbolique pour la profession
c'est une initiative prise par patrick
ollier le maire de rueil malmaison qui
est également président de la métropole
du grand paris des fruits et légumes à
prix cassés dans quatre boutiques
éphémères de rueil malmaison
c'est l'opération paniers solidaires que
nous raconte olivier un état pour un
grand paris à regarder des produits de
saisons disponibles tous les jours même
dans les quartiers sans supermarché la
ville de rueil malmaison a ouvert quatre
boutiques éphémères pour faciliter la
vie des confiné ce sont les commerçants
du marché qui ont pris place ici
résultat les habitants se ravitaillent
près de chez eux en produits 100% frais
j'ai pu acheter des voeux de la volaille
des primeurs de prix des légumes du
fromage pour les habitants les plus
modestes la ville a lancé mi-avril
l'opération paniers solidaires des
paniers de fruits et légumes à prix
cassés ils sont distribués par des
bénévoles
la solidarité joue à plein dans cette
ville des hauts-de-seine
des habitants se sont portés volontaires
pour apporter des colis de légumes
fabriquer et distribuer des masques
cette réserve citoyenne j'aurais jamais
cru qu et 1300 personnes qui
s'inscrivent donc oui il ya un élan de
solidarité né lente générosité ça
m'étonne pas des ruines à 0 ils sont
naturellement généreux mais là ils
démontrent qu'ils le sont réellement
ils s'engagent ils prennent le risque
dans la rue et d'aller distribuer des
masques donné boîte aux lettres ni
prenne ce risque
chaque foyer de rueil malmaison recevra
masque dans la perspective du
déconfinement les masques sont en cours
de distribution et pour compléter nos
stocks de la ville 280 couturières
bénévoles de la commune ont sorti en
machine à coudre
voilà tout à fait autre chose maintenant
vous le savez sans doute le ministère de
l'intérieur autorise de nouveau les
adoptions d'animaux un assouplissement
des règles destinées à éviter la
saturation des refuges un soulagement
pour notre invité le président de la
société protectrice des animaux jacques
charles fombonne bonjour jacques charles
fombonne merci d'être l'invitée du grand
jt des territoires aujourd'hui
bonjour monsieur viguier alors jacques
charles fombonne depuis et
l'autorisation donnée par le
gouvernement d'autoriser les gens à se
rendre dans vos refuge et bien est-ce
que cela va mieux
est-ce que vous avez des chiffres à nous
communiquer aujourd'hui
oui absolument c'est à dire qu'on fait
nous avons rétabli le flux des animaux
entre en a c'est à dire ce que nous
recueillons en sortie de fourrière et
sortants c'est à dire ce que nous
proposons à des familles à l'adoption
alors le ministère de l'intérieur a
entendu notre appel et il a autorisé
avec une dérogation supplémentaire le
fait de pouvoir venir dans les refuges
et à ce jour c'est à dire on
en trois quatre petites journées nous
avons réalisé près de 250 adoption on
est vraiment content de ce résultat qui
va nous permettre de retrouver un peu de
un peu de large un peu de place jacques
charles fombonne président de la spa qui
est notre invité dans le grand jt des
territoires
quid des animaux de compagnie rester
chez eux dans des logements inoccupés
lorsque par exemple leurs maîtres sont
amené d'urgence à l'hôpital par les
pompiers
que que deviennent ces animaux est ce
que vous avez des solutions pour cela en
fait les choses se passent d'une façon
très administrative les pompiers les
policiers les gendarmes ou la police
municipale qui intervient sur les lieux
où une personne et et part pour
l'hôpital remettent à ce moment-là
l'animal à la fourrière service
municipal la fourrière va garder
l'animal éventuellement jusqu'au moment
où la personne pourra sortir de
l'hôpital et sinon elle sera confiée à
une à une association
je pense que dans ce cas là on peut
déroger évidemment à notre règle
habituelle c'est-à-dire que l'on
conserve l'animal il n'est pas question
de le mettre à l'adoption
mais lorsque la personne sort de
l'hôpital on lui remet évidemment ça
restera son animal on dit aussi que la
france est championne d'europe des
abandons des animaux de compagnie
notamment à l' approche des vacances
estivales
est ce vrai d'abord et comment expliquez
vous cette attitude de la part de
nombreux concitoyens qu'ils adoptent des
animaux puis les abandonne pour ce qui
concerne la société protectrice des
animaux nous en avons recueilli l'an
dernier 46 milles
je suis pas certains ont dit que nous
sommes effectivement les champions du
monde de au moins des champions d'europe
de l'adoption
je vous avoue que j'ai aucun aucun moyen
de comparaison des causes il y en a
plusieurs il y a d'abord concernant les
chats l'absence de stérilisation la
stérilisation des chats errants
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut
que les mairies prennent en compte il ya
un deuxième
un deuxième axe de recherche pour
l'abandon et contre lequel la spa lutte
vivement c'est la vente des animaux dans
les animaleries
c'est de la vente c'est à dire que
l'animal vous est présentée dans une
galerie commerciale dans un magasin on
passe cinq fois dix fois devant personne
est capable de résister à l'attrait
qu'un chiot ou un chaton parce qu'il
n'ya que très jeunes animaux ont fini
par lâcheté pour soi plaisir aux enfants
à noël et six mois après l'animal le
chien fait 15 kg 20 kilos on peut pas
l'emmener et à ce moment là voilà
bandage
je rappelle là c'est le général de
gendarmerie qui parle que l'abandon
c'est un délit on encourt deux ans
d'emprisonnement 30000 euros d'amendé et
une inscription au casier judiciaire
voilà merci jacques charles fombonne
vous êtes je le rappelle le président de
la spa merci d'avoir été l'invitée du
grand jt des territoires aujourd'hui
tout à fait autre chose maintenant
considéré comme non essentiels par le
gouvernement les librairies ont dû
baisser leur rideau le 16 mars dernier
vous le savez sans doute mais certaines
d'entre elles ont décidé de mettre en
place un service de drive c'est le cas
de la librairie du pavé du canal à
montigny le bretonneux
aurélie rose et patrick jacques de
dixmude pour tv 78 sont à les feuilleter
quelques livres pour nous regarder
continuer l'activité de la librairie
pour vendre son stock
voici ce qui a poussé laurent garin
directeur du pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux de rouvrir les portes de son
établissement une ouverture partielle
puisqu'il propose à ses clients un point
relais un service qui était encore
impossible il ya quelques jours il ya eu
un appui du pardon de la part du
syndicat de la librairie française pour
que ça passe enfin comme un produit de
première nécessité donc on n'y a plus de
ya plus de restrictions en soit sur le
déplacement avec justificatifs pour
venir acheter les niveaux je suis venu
le récupérer des suites de bande
dessinée pour les enfants qui lisent
beaucoup en ce moment à la maison et qui
sont dedans pour les commandes tout se
passe en ligne
l'électeur vérifie que les livres soient
bien disponible et envoient leur demande
par mail
le paiement se fait uniquement par
chèque a décidé de pas avoir plus de 2 3
personnes par créneau par quart d'heure
donc ils prennent date sur un rendez
vous ici et ils nous envoient un mail
avec une liste et nous on leur envoie le
montant de la commande en leur précisant
que le créneau a été validée qui a dû
j'habite hydro alcoolique il ya
forcément on sait un mètre de distance
entre la clientèle et moi mais voilà
donc les gens viennent sur ces créneaux
et voilà comment on fonctionne lecture
j'ai pas mal de bouquins parce que
j'avais j'ai toujours un stock sous la
main et j'en avais pris aussi à la
médiathèque
mais c'était surtout la possibilité de
soutenir un vrai que c'est important de
le soutenir les commerces locaux et le
centre ville qui est important de se
mentir
plus de quarante mille ouvrages sont en
stock parmi les plus plébiscités les
livres jeunesse et les livres de cuisine
voilà des yvelines nous partons dans le
nord vous savez chaque camp jt des
territoires nous recevons un patron de
la presse quotidienne régionale ou d'une
grande télévision locale ou régionale
aujourd'hui est bien en duplex de lille
c'est jean michel lobry bonjour jean
michel lobry vous êtes le pdg de wéo une
chaîne du groupe rossel qui possède
également la voix du nord bourg jean
michel bonjour selvig est alors jean
michel lobry comment avez vous pu
fonctionner pendant cette période
comment a pu marcher wéo la grande
chaîne tnt du nord
l'organisation est très simple toutes
celles et ceux qui travaillent pour la
chaîne sont à distance nous avons mis au
point un système de réalisation des
missions à distance chacun peut
intervenir de son domicile ou d'un lieu
déportés et avec ce système nous
réalisons depuis le début du confinement
un peu plus de deux heures de programmes
par jour au service du territoire et de
ses habitants
jean michel lobry vous êtes donc le pdg
de wéo une chaîne du groupe rossel
recèle qui possède la voix du nord le
grand quotidien régional des hauts de
france
comment avez vous pu organiser le
travail en trio et la voix du nord
pendant cette période de confinement par
la collaboration et quotidienne avec la
voix du nord mais aussi avec le courrier
picard pour pour la picardie et qui
appartient à notre groupe
parce que
ces médias là comme nous on s'est
vraiment mis dans la posture de rendre
service en donnant de l'information
concrète pratique en participant au
mouvement de solidarité en lançant des
mouvements de collecte de fonds pour
ceux qui en ont besoin
c'est tout le temps 7 cette
collaboration et c'est fondamental pour
remplir notre rôle de deux services de
services au public
jean michel lobry il y aura un après
crise on se dit qu'on finira le 11 mai
pour vos chaînes sans doute il y aura
beaucoup de changements à venir
notamment dans le modèle est ce qu'il y
aura forcément un modèle économique
nouveau qui va voir le jour
il sera certainement modifier parce que
une chaîne comme ohio a multiplié ses
audiences par 2,6 depuis le début du
conflit en face mais comme les autres
médias
nous n'avons pas la ressource
publicitaire qui a été qui a été
dynamisée à notre chiffre d'affaires
publicitaire on en est à 20 % de nos
objectifs
donc ça veut dire qu économiquement un
éditeur comme ou héros va devoir se
poser des bonnes questions pour
rationaliser ses charges et sortir au
mieux de la crise notre chance est
d'avoir un groupe puissant et qui va qui
va nous soutenir donc nous survivrons et
nous survivrons d'autant plus que nous
avons nous avons développé
le contact les contacts chaque jour on
est au contact en linéaire et digitale
de plus de 300000 personnes sur notre
territoire à audience à l'appui merci
jean michel lobry d'avoir été invité du
grand jt des territoires êtes le pdg de
wéo la chaîne du groupe possède la
grande chaîne tnt des hauts de france
voilà qui diffuse ce grand jt des
territoires bien sûr je sais pas
jean-michel si ça va vous arriver en
plein confinement chacun s'occupe comme
il peut pour nicholas monroe
l'occupation est toute trouvée c'est du
sport et pas qu'un peu ce jeune manceau
s'est fixé pour objectif de battre le
record du monde d'abdos pour cela ils
s'entraînent tous les jours du lundi au
dimanche chez lui
record à battre pour le jeune homme de
21 ans faire plus de 6000 788 abdos en
une heure eliane galiana pour lm tv
sarthe n'a pas relevé le défi mais
regardez ce qu'il fait lui c'est une
vidéo que j'avais vues sur youtube suis
tombé sur l'ancien champion du monde
roger prévaut donc c'est quand même un
athlète de 80 ha non donc son âge
m'avait choqué je me suis renseigné sur
ce rôle lui c'est un ancien bodybuilder
avec un gros palmarès de musculation
donc j'ai vu son ca vidéo son record et
je me suis dit pourquoi pas moi quoique
je m'entraîne pour rire se dit pourquoi
pas
[Musique]
ah je m'entraîne tous les jours c'est un
entraînement régulier donc c'est du
lundi au dimanche vraiment très très peu
de repos ou alors quelques jours avec
des intensités plus faible que les
autres jours donc c'est un exercice qui
demande un entraînement chaque jour qui
demandent du souffle et du moins du
cardio et c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
répéter pour eux pour progresser quoi
alors d'aujourd'hui au niveau des abdos
c'est plus compliqué parce que on va
dire que je me sens plus rien au niveau
des abdos et c'est plus au niveau du
souffle au niveau du coeur donc c'est là
faut que je travaille au niveau du cac
radio et au niveau des abdos tout ce qui
est contre contractions musculaires tout
ce qui est douleur je ressens plus rien
on va dire donc à force de travail et il
ya la douleur n'est plus présente avec
le confinement c'est assez compliqué
parce que néanmoins j'aimerais bien que
ça soit organisée par pas des caméras
main par des professionnels avec le
confinement c'est assez compliqué donc
faut que je m'organise dans tout ça dans
pour filmer pour conter trouver
quelqu'un qui doit compter que chez les
mets tout donc c'est assez compliqué
mais on va trouver une solution
voilà bravo nicolas bodereau superman
est donc en sarthe
on l'a trouvé il est dans nos
territoires voilà pour ceux qui nous
regardent n'hésitez pas à nous faire
part de votre envie de challenge et
nicolas fois la fin de second vite et
des territoires merci de nous avoir
suivis vous savez qu'il a été réalisé
avec l'ensemble des chaînes de la tnt
régionale et locale
et bien sûr nous sommes diffusée sur tv5
monde nous saluons nos compatriotes qui
se trouvent à l'étranger
à très vite pour une prochaine édition
au revoir à tous et surtout bon courage
au revoir
[Musique]